المترجم: Fatima Zahra El Hafa
المدقّق: Lalla Khadija Tigha
سأذهب غدا لأنتاركتيكا
من أجل تحقيق حلمي.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
هل تعلمون أين تتواجد أنتاركتيكا؟
هي القارة السابعة،
التي يتواجد بها القطب الجنوبي.
هي القارة الأبرد في العالم،
سُجِّلت فيها درجة حرارة 98 درجة تحت الصفر.
وأعلى سرعة رياح،
إذ تصل إلى 300 كيلومتر في الساعة.
(هتاف)
هي قارة متجمدة، لا يعيش فيها أحد.
باستثناء العلماء المتواجدين بها
لإنجاز البحوث.
والمغامرين الذين يرتادونها
من أجل تحقيق تحديات،
مثل الرحلة التي سأقوم بها غدًا.
(تصفيق)
سأذهب من أجل تسلق أعلى قمة بها،
قمة فانسون.
وهي آخر قمة متبقية لي
في مشروع القمم السبع.
وهو تسلق أعلى قمة في كل قارة.
بتسلقي لهذه القمة،
سأحقق حلمي بتسلق القمم السبع،
وسأصبح أول مغربية تحقق هذا الإنجاز.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
أنا خائفة من هذه الرحلة.
وفي نفس الوقت، متحمسة لها.
أنا خائفة لأننا دائما نخاف المجهول،
لأنه يُخرجنا من منطقة راحتنا.
ومتحمسة لأنني أرغب في التعرف
على هذا العالم الجديد.
أستكشف هذا العالم الجديد الذي سأذهب إليه.
وهذا مصدر حماس ودافع بالنسبة لي.
ما زلت أتذكر عام 2011،
بعد تسلقي لمجموعة من القمم المغربية،
قررت تسلق أعلى قمة أفريقية،
وهي كليمنجارو،
التي يبلغ طولها 5895 متراً،
وهناك اكتشفت مشروع القمم السبع.
عرفت بأنه مشروع صعب، وبأنه يشمل قمة إفرست.
وأنه مكلِّف.
ومع ذلك تجرأت أن أحلم،
وقلت: "لِم لا؟"
سأحاول وسأرى أين سأصل.
بالفعل، أول ما بدأت به هو تعلم تسلق الجبال
في مون بلون.
وهناك اكتسبت الثقة في النفس،
وقررت الشروع في هذه التجربة.
كانت الجبال التي تسلقتها مدرسة كبيرة،
علمتني دروسًا كثيرة.
تعلمت أن أتجرأ وأحلم في الكليمانجارو،
تعلمت الصبر في قمة إلبروس في أوروبا.
تعلمت أنه لا وجود للفشل،
حين ذهبت لتسلق أكونكاجوا،
أعلى قمة في أمريكا الجنوبية.
لم أنجح في البداية، لكنني لم أستسلم.
ظللت أعمل وعدت إليها مرة أخرى،
ونجحت في تسلقها.
تعلمت تحدي الذات، عندما ذهبت لتسلق دينالي،
أعلى قمة في أمريكا الشمالية.
تعلمت كيف أن على الإنسان مواجهة المجهول،
عندما زرت قبائل بابوا غينيا،
لتسلق قمة كارستينز في أوقيانوسيا.
لا أخفيكم أنني مررت بمراحل صعبة،
جعلتني أشك في نفسي.
بكيت أيامها، وكنت على وشك التخلي عن حلمي.
ولكن بالصبر والإصرار والعزيمة،
استمريت في طريقي.
كانت هناك أيضا تحديات مادية كبيرة،
إذ كان علي العثور على ممولين،
ولا أخفيكم أن الأمر كان صعبًا جدًّا.
ولكنني تعلمت كيفية تبليغ فكرتي.
تعلمت كيفية البحث عن ممولين وإقناعهم لدعمي
بالطبع، لا يمكن للإنسان أن ينجح لوحده.
كان هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
ممن ساعدوني وساندوني،
حتى أنجح.
وعلى رأسهم عائلتي.
فقد ساندني زوجي ورافقني إلى كلًّ
من الكليمانجارو والمخيم الرئيسي في إفرست
كانت عائلتي كذلك تساندني،
إذ كنت أذهب وأترك ابنتي في رعايتهم
وأنا كلي اطمئنان.
بطبيعة الحال، لم تكن ابنتي راضية عن الوضع؛
سفر والدتها وتركها إياها.
في البداية، كانت تبكي وكان هذا يؤثر عليّ،
لأنها كانت تشكل نقطة ضعفي.
كنت أحس وكأنني شخص أناني
بتركي لابنتي ومنزلي واختفائي لمدة طويلة.
ولكن لابد من التضحيات من أجل تحقيق النجاح.
عند عودتي، أحاول تعويض ابنتي
بمنحها الحب والحنان.
وهي تفتخر الآن بوالدتها،
وتتخذها قدوة لها في الحياة.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
كان تسلق قمة إفرست من بين القمم،
ولكن لم أعره تركيزي التام،
فقد كنت أتقدم خطوة بخطوة.
كانت كل قمة بالنسبة لي،
تدريبًا لتسلق إفرست.
عندما أحسست بقرب تسلقي له،
وهنا نتحدث عن الحدس،
بدأت الاستعداد بشكل مكثف.
قمت بمجموعة من التداريب في جبال الهملايا،
كما تسلقت قممًا بعلو 7000 متر.
ذهبت لجبال الألب واسكتلندا وإسبانيا.
قمت كذلك بتدريبات مكثفة:
من ثلاث إلى أربع ساعات
من التدريبات الرياضية يوميًّا.
ليست القوة الجسدية هي الوحيدة التي تهم،
فالقوة الذهنية مهمة أيضًا.
كنت أتأمل وأمارس اليوغا وتطوير النفس.
قرأت عن قمة إفرست، وكنت أعلم
أن تسلقها صعب وأن الناس يموتون أثناء ذلك.
ولكن هذا لم يشعرني بالخوف،
لأننا الموت يأتي حينما يقدره الله.
لذا من يستحسن أن نعيش حياتنا بالكامل.
(تصفيق)
استغرقت رحلة إفرست شهرين،
أبريل وماي 2017.
كان الشهر الأول مخصصا للتأقلم،
إذ كنا نتسلق صعودًا وهبوطًا
ليتأقلم الجسم مع العلو،
ومع قلة الأكسجين والضغط.
في البداية، وأثناء عبوري
لمنحدر خومبو الجليدي،
وهو من أخطر المنحدرات، كنت خائفة جدًّا.
بعدها، اعتدت على الأمر،
نظرًا لكثرة عبوري له.
واعتدت كذلك على سماع
صوت الانهيارات الثلجية،
ومغادرة خيمتي مهرولة لأشاهدها.
إنه لغريب كيف يمكن للإنسان
التأقلم مع الصعوبات.
تلزمة فقط القدرة والشجاعة لمواجهتها.
وهناك يكتشف أن لديه موارد كثيرة،
وبأنه يستطيع الذهاب أبعد من الحدود
التي وضعها هو لنفسه، أو وضعها له المجتمع.
كنت أحاول استغلال اللحظة الحاضرة،
وأن أعيش اللحظة عندما كنت هناك.
كنت أحاول التمتع بالمناظر الطبيعية
الرائعة التي كنت أشاهدها.
كنت أحس بالامتنان لتواجدي هناك.
إن الظروف الصعبة والقاسية
هي ما يجعل الإنسان يحس بقيمة الأشياء
التي كان يعتبرها من البديهيات.
مثل الماء والأكل والأكسجين.
تواجدي في المخيم الرئيسي
لإفرست لمدة طويلة،
مكنني من النعرف على مجموعة
من متسلقي الجبال من مختلف دول العالم.
استفدت من تجاربهم وعشت رفقتهم لحظات رائعة.
وهذا يعلمك التعايش وتقدير الآخر،
بغض النظر عن جنسيته وعن دينه،
ودون أحكام مسبقة.
بعد شهر من التدريبات، بقينا ننتظر.
الانتظار يكون صعبًا،
خاصة في الظروف القاسية.
ولكن يجب على الشخص
أن يضع هدفه نصب عينيه دائمًا.
عند حلول الظروف المناخية المناسبة،
بدأت المشي رفقة مرشدي،
وهو من الأشخاص الذين يتواجدون بالمنطقة.
صعدنا حتى المخيم الرابع،
المتواجد على علو 8000 متر.
هناك ندخل منطقة الموت،
التي تتوفر على ثلث الأكسجين فقط.
يبدأ الجسم بالتدهور بسرعة كبيرة جدًّا،
وبالتالي يستحسن أن لا يبقى الشخص هناك
لمدة طويلة، لأن حتى النوم لا يشعره بالراحة
لم نكن سننام هناك ليلتها،
إذ كان علينا الاتجاه
صوب القمة في تلك الليلة.
ولكن كانت الرياح قوية.
وواجهنا مشكلا آخر:
تعطل جهاز الأكسجين الخاص بمرشدي.
فكان علينا المبيت في المخيم الرابع،
على علو 8000 متر.
والأكثر من ذلك،
طلب مني المرشد أن أشاركه الأكسجين.
نحن معتادون على تقاسم الأكل والماء،
(ضحك)
لكن الأكسجين؟ لم نفكر بذلك قط.
لكنني لم أرفض،
لأن المشاركة من أهم القيم لدي.
فشاركته الأكسجين.
(تصفيق)
وبما أن الخلايا العصبية كما تعلمون،
تموت بسبب قلة الأكسجين،
فقد استيقظت صباحًا وأنا أتساءل
إذا ما كنت لا أزال أفكر أم لا.
وقمت ببعض العمليات الذهنية:
اثنان ضرب اثنان كم تساوي؟
وعندما أجبت بأربعة، قلت الحمد لله.
ما زلت قادرة على التفكير.
في اليوم الموالي،
انطلقنا مع التاسعة والنصف ليلًا.
ولكن قبل انطلاقنا، قلت في نفسي:
"لا بد وأن هناك سببًا ما".
فبالأمس، كانت الرياح قويَّة
ولم يصل أحد للقمة.
إذن لحسن الحظ أنني لم أصل.
وهنا تظهر أهمية القوة الروحية.
لأنني كنت مستسلمة،
كنت قد وضعت نفسي في يد الله.
وأقول في قرارة نفسي
بأن كل ما يأتيني من عند الله خير.
وفعلًا كان من الخير
أننا لم نذهب تلك الليلة.
في اليوم الموالي، انطلقنا نحو القمة
على الساعة الناسعة والنصف ليلًا.
بمجرد ما بدأت المشي ليلًا،
حتى انطفأ مصباحي.
لم أستسلم، واستمريت في الصعود.
النظارات التي كنت أضعها لحماية العينين،
تجمدت بفعل الطقس البارد.
إذ كانت الحرارة آنذاك 30 درجة تحت الصفر.
وكانت الرياح قوية نسبيًّا.
أزلت النظارات واستمريت في الصعود.
مررت بجثث،
تجاوزتها واستمريت في الصعود.
لم أكن أفكر في أي شيء،
كنت مركزة على هدفي ولم أحس بأي شيء.
حتى أحاسيسي تجمدت.
(ضحك)
بعد عشر ساعات من التسلق والمشي والمعاناة،
وصلت لإفرست، أعلى قمة في العالم.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
كان منظرًا رائعًا.
كنت أرى هضبة "التبت" من هنا
ووادي "خومبو" أسفل مني.
كنت فوق السحاب والضباب.
(ضحك)
ضباب لم يكن بإمكاني جمعه.
كنت فوق القمم،
وأحسست بأنني صغيرة جدًّا أمام خلق الله.
أحسست بالامتنان لأن الله منحني القوة
والقدرة للوصول إلى القمة.
وأحسست بالحرية.
بعد 20 دقيقة على تواجدي هناك،
أدركت أنني لم أنته بعد،
إذ يتوجب على الهبوط.
(ضحك)
ثمانون بالمائة من الحوادث
تقع أثناء الهبوط.
لأن الشخص يكون متحمسًا جدَّا للوصول.
ولكن بمجرد وصوله، يكتشف أنه استنزف قواه
أو الأكسجين الخاص به.
وبمجرد ما بدأت في النزول،
وكما أخبرتكم فقد أزلت نظاراتي،
تأثرت عيناي بالأشعة فوق البنفسجية.
فلم أعد أستطيع الرؤية بشكل جيد،
كانت رؤيتي ضبابية.
(ضحك)
حينها تساءلت
إذا ما كنت سأستطيع العودة أم لا.
عند وصولي للمخيم الرابع،
اكتشفت بأن أطراف أصابعي تجمدت بفعل البرد.
أُصبت بقضمة صقيع.
من المؤكد أن طريق النجاح ليس سهلًا.
لكن لا بد من التضحيات والمعاناة
لكي يحقق الفرد نجاحه.
القمة التي سأذهب إليها غدًا هي قمة فينسون.
بطبيعة الحال، هي ليست بعلو إفرست.
ولكن صعوبتها تكمن في تواجدها
بقارة أنتاركتيكا.
التي تتميز، كما أخبرتكم سابقًا،
بظروف مناخية صعبة جدًّا.
سأذهب غدًا إلى الشيلي،
ستكون انطلاقتي من هناك.
ثم سأتجه صوب بونتا أريناس،
وهي أقصى نقطة في الشيلي.
وانطلاقًا من هناك،
سأستقل طائرة أخرى صوب القطب الجنوبي،
وسنصل سلسلة الجبال الجليدية.
ثم بعدها سنستقل طائرة أخرى
من نوع توين أوتر،
للوصول إلى المخيم الرئيسي لفينسون،
وهناك سنباشر المشي.
سنستمر في المشي لعشرة أيام تقريبًا.
عندها سنصل للقمة، ثم سنعود أدراجنا.
وبالتالي فصعوبة هذه القمة تكمن
في ظروفها المناخية الصعبة.
هناك عوامل تقنية.
ولكن مثل أي قمة، كيفما كانت،
فهي تتميز بصعوبتها ويجب التحضير لها مسبقا
وتحمل صعوبات وتحديات ودروسًا نستفيد منها.
كما ترون، فأنا سأذهب غدًا لتحقيق حلمي،
وأنتم، أين وصلت أحلامكم؟
(تصفيق وهتاف)
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)